this video is brought to you by ren
[Music]
what's up guys michael here if you're
any brand of cinephile you've probably
heard about the very weird french movie
that's taken the film world by storm
that's right taton most widely known for
featuring sexual acts with cars that if
shown here might make youtube
spontaneously combust the film's
director julia ducorno won the uber
prestigious palm door at khan and her
work has scandalized the internet
because tldr sex with cars and since its
very recent release on vod it's set to
horrify and delight anyone willing to
fork over a few bucks to watch it but
when you look beyond the kinks is the
film actually smart let's find out in
this wisecrack edition on tatan deep or
dumb and spoilers ahead for an
unlookawayable film that if you can
stomach you should run out and see in
theaters or at least catch on vod from
the comfort of your blanket fort
but before we dive in i want to tell you
about this video sponsor wren if you've
looked at the news lately or even just
at your local weather report chances are
the climate change is on your mind and
with all of the dire threats facing our
planet is easy to feel helpless and
stressed out but ren can help you
transform your concern for the climate
into tangible action first you take
their quick and easy quiz to calculate
the exact size of your carbon footprint
from there ren suggests exactly how
invested you can become in their
impactful climate initiative so you can
offset your negative impact on the
planet as someone that lives in
california i was especially impressed
with ren's biochar project which removes
dead trees from redwood forest and high
fire risk areas they'd turn these trees
into biochar a stable form of carbon
that lasts for thousands of years and
while i'm extra pumped about rent's
projects that are local to me their work
resonates around the world there's their
mineral weathering project in scotland
for instance which turns atmospheric
carbon into solid rock all using
accelerated natural geological processes
to get started with ren all you have to
do is answer a few questions about your
lifestyle like what's in your diet how
often you travel and whether or not you
personally identify with any of the
villains from captain planet okay not
that one while a zero carbon lifestyle
is impossible ren can help you offset
what's left over once you sign up to
make a monthly contribution that will be
used to offset your carbon footprint
you'll receive monthly updates from the
projects you support so you will
actually see the impact that you are
making red has pledged to plant 10 extra
trees for the first 100 people who sign
up using our referral link so go to
slash
www.wren.com
to join us in saving the rainforest and
fighting the climate crisis that's ren
dot co slash start slash wisecrack and
now back to the show now ducorno has
earned a reputation for her unique brand
of body horror one of her short films
features an adolescent girl whose skin
starts shedding while her featured debut
depicts a young vegetarian transforming
into a cannibal so the natural starting
point for any conversation about her
latest work seems to be body horror now
do corner didn't invent body horror this
specific sub-genre has a storied history
of making people puke in movie theaters
as bodies explode organs get eaten and
so on or
so i've heard because if you know me you
know i don't like spooky things
body horror is pretty much categorically
shocking but in our opinion it's at its
best when the horrifically gross body
stuff is functioning on a deeper level
long live the new flesh that is when
it's a metaphor take david cronenberg's
classic the fly in which a scientist
accidentally merges genes with a fly and
slowly turns into a giant fugly insect
the grossness is beyond debate and not
just if you're a partial to the spooky
parts of life but it's more than shock
value
the scientist transformation could be
seen as a metaphor for the way his
disgusted girlfriend feels about him
it's about starting to find the person
you love to be kind of gross and
abhorrent that is to say it's pretty
deep it's iton's unique brand of body
horror kicks off with a car crash that
leaves the protagonist alexia with a
titanium plate in her child-sized head
and of course viewers get to witness the
surgery taking place on a child's open
skull here alexia's human body merges
with the material specifically titanium
the coldness of being part metal
functions metaphorically to explain
grown-up alexia's lack of humanity this
allows her to act like a psychopathic
killer and to want to [ __ ] cars a
neglectful childhood has created an
adult who prefers the cold touch of
steel over the warmth of flesh-bound
humanity then there's her inevitable
post-hanky-panky with car pregnancy you
heard that right she [ __ ] a car and the
car gets her pregnant she clearly never
heard of car condoms which are actually
a thing there's a story tradition in
horror films like rosemary's baby and
the brood of depicting pregnancy as the
ultimate well horror pregnancy becomes a
metaphor for women not having autonomy
or control over their bodies whether
it's because of abortion bans or just
the straight-up dangers and pains of
childbirth we see some of this into
taunt when an on the lam alexia tries to
pose as firefighter vincent's missing
son she increasingly struggles to
control her body to hide her obvious
pregnancy and her breasts in a way that
personally made me squirm so hard i
almost had an aneurysm but tatang goes
beyond the well-worn narrative where
pregnancy is simply a gory embodiment of
women's lack of social and political
capital there's also vincent who
compulsively injects steroids and scenes
that again made me nearly crawl out of
my seat in search of more wholesome
content
that's better anyway both alexia and
vincent's bodies grow increasingly
grotesque over the course of the film
alexia's itchy body leaks motor fluid
vincent's muscles strain and his butt
gets more bruised but the strange thing
here is this the more grotesque their
bodies become the more human they become
as their genuine shared emotional bond
deepens ducorno has said that her work
is primarily about embracing the total
grossness of occupying a human body with
all of its smells and hairs and other
yuck factors as in her other films she
depicts a more nuanced version of body
horror than your typical fair
grotesqueness she seems to declare is
fundamentally human and that's not only
okay it's part of what makes us lovable
now i'm tempted to make fart noises with
my armpits but instead i'll just declare
this aspect of tatan decidedly deep
before we move on another spoiler alert
the next two sections will reveal
something about the final scene of the
movie so get off your roited butt and go
watch it anyway the next lens to view to
taunt through is the complexities of
gender roles see do core notes after
acting newcomer a roussel specifically
because of her androgynous appearance
this makes sense as alexia spends most
of the film posing as a boy when we
first meet alexia she's erotic dancing
at a car show for the oggling eyes of
predatory men this is fitting for a
woman who yes we hear you has sex with
cars in this scene alexia is heavily
objectified essentially treated like
she's as inhuman as the literal cards
that she's dancing on this suggests not
unlike plenty of feminist film scholars
have long been saying that having your
body viewed through the male gaze can be
highly dehumanizing but over the course
of the film alexia becomes increasingly
androgynous as she impersonates a
missing boy in the process she also
starts to become more human and actually
forms a caring relationship with her
quote unquote father vincent abandoning
the classic performative erotic
femininity that made her such a hit at
the car shows then makes alexia
explicitly more human in a similar vein
vincent injects himself with steroids as
he clings to the vestiges of his
youthful potent masculinity he craves
strength and enjoys wielding power over
those around him and yet he like the
other firefighters seems happiest when
dancing often in pretty homoerotic
scenes always devoid of any women
surrendering his pursuit of classic
masculinity even for just a moment
actually lets him live life more fully
it's fitting then that the film ends
with vincent cradling alexia's newborn
baby like you might expect a mother to
ducorno is showing the toxicity of
conforming to both stereotypical
femininity and stereotypical masculinity
in doing so she seems to advocate for
embracing all aspects of yourself
regardless of so-called gender
affiliations in order to live a more
full meaningful life again i'm gonna go
with pretty deep before we get into the
third point a third spoiler alert for
all you easily distracted monsters go
support this film before you watch on
the final lens for viewing this film is
through the context of chosen family you
see alexia's birth parents are portrayed
as cold and unfeeling in fact her
father's impatience with alexia causes
the very car crash that lands her with a
metal plate in her head rather than
replicate this dynamic alexia chooses to
detach from people and as a grown woman
can only experience love or feel passion
for cars yes damn it we get it she has
sex with cars but when alexia assumes
the role of vincent's son she re-enters
traditional familial ties there's a
major twist though pretending to be
vincent's son allows alexia to finally
forge an authentic human connection that
is lying about who she is and pretending
to be a part of a family lets her learn
to actually be human meanwhile vincent's
been mourning his missing son for years
that lost attaches him from the world
and even from his firefighter bros who
would gladly fill that emotional void at
first vincent needs to believe that
alexia is his actual son to love her but
over time as he starts to genuinely care
for her he also stops caring about her
true identity through learning to love
alexia vincent realizes that blood isn't
the deepest tie this all culminates in
the birth of alexia's car baby a super
not safe for work scene vincent
instantly accepts the baby as his own
loving and cradling it despite it not
being genetically his he seems to have
given up his fixation on blood ties in
this way and quite ironically the film's
fake family is actually the one that's
capable of being nurturing and loving we
think the savvy do corneau has a lot to
say here she's trying to disconnect love
from specific identities like mother
father or son in this way she's
challenging us to rethink how much we
equate love with certain social romantic
and familial structures this honestly is
really cool and a rare thing to see on
the big screen especially because
hollywood tends to put traditional
relationships on a pedestal so thrice i
say titan is deep and that just about
covers it titan ultimately is a lot more
than merely shocking it genuinely seems
to have a lot to say about bodies gender
and families zoukorno for her part has
claimed that the film is primarily a
story about love for her all the
salaciously gory details are merely a
symbolic means for telling that story
and when you dig deeper this makes a lot
of sense but what do you guys think is
there more to tatan than a roll in the
hay with an automobile or are we trying
to dress a minivan up as a suburban let
us know in the comments big thanks to
our patrons for all your support and
don't forget to check out our podcast
hit that subscribe button like you're
shoving a hairpin into the ear of an
unwanted suitor and don't forget to ring
that bell and as always thanks for
watching later
[Music]
you